remember evergrand in late september and
early october of last year they were the
star of financial news everyone was
worried about what would happen if this
massive chinese institution defaulted on
their debt and ripple effects that it
would have on the world we saw headlines
like fed warns china's property problems
could hurt global markets and the u.s
economy and wall street mark's biggest
drop since may as evergrain crisis
intensifies yet as the fed started
raising interest rates and the stock
market started to off for other reasons
it seems that most people have
completely forgotten about this once
monumental threat this isn't to say that
the evergreen situation can be
completely ignored though as the crisis
has only gotten worse
in fact at the end of last year
evergreen defaulted on 1.2 billion worth
of foreign bonds and as you would guess
their stock price has only fallen
further and further into the abyss
standing at just 17 cents today so
whatever happened to the ever grand
crisis and does evergreen even matter on
a world scale
before we get into the potential
consequences of the evergrand crisis
let's first take a look at how this
crisis even formed in the first place
this was not something that just took
place over a matter of years rather this
issue has actually been ruined for
decades going all the way back to the
1970s you see it in 1978 the chinese
government adopted a new economic policy
that many scholars call china's open
door policy before this ideology was
adopted china was completely closed off
to the world economy they practiced an
ideology called zhongju wei tia zhijuwe
yong which translates to chinese
learning as substance western learning
for application as the name suggests
china was intent on maintaining the
traditional culture as well as their
communist political and economic systems
however they were willing to import
technology from the west and implement
it into their society while this
strategy worked decently from much of
the 1900s it came with a slew of
shortfalls first of all china was barely
involved in foreign trade and secondly
no one wanted to invest in china which
made it increasingly difficult to keep
up with the west not to mention china's
economic and political landscapes had
been devastated by the cultural
revolution which took place between 1966
and 1976. so in 1978 china finally gave
in and adopted the open door policy
things didn't just change overnight
though china spent years deciding which
sectors they needed to control and which
sectors they could loosen up china was
by no means willing to give up land
ownership but they were willing to
privatize how the land was used and this
brings us to the amendment act of 1988
this amendment made it possible for
companies and individuals to use land to
their liking by obtaining land use
rights
this opened the door to a wide number of
entrepreneurs who were looking to build
real estate and property development
companies and as you would guess
african's founder zuzian fell under this
category zoo was actually a bit late to
this trend as he didn't start evergreen
until 1996 which is eight years after
the amendment was adopted
nonetheless evergrande would leverage
this new opportunity to the max and the
company would grow exponentially over
the next two decades effortless growth
was only further accelerated by china
joining the world trade organization in
2001 this made chinese investments more
appealing than ever before which allowed
evergreen to grow an international base
of investors and stakeholders
every grand actually went public during
the height of the great financial
recession in october of 2009 but despite
this they were still able to raise 722
million dollars which just goes to show
how much interest there was in chinese
real estate amongst international
investors all of these factors would
allow evergrand to become one of the
largest property developers in china and
one of the biggest companies in the
world
in fact the company was and still is
part of the global 500 coming in at rank
122. this monumental growth that didn't
come for free though evergrand was
constantly taking on more and more risk
which would eventually come back to
haunt them
one of the biggest risks of the chinese
real estate market over the past two
decades has been their ever-growing real
estate bubble one of the most famous
examples of this is the dozens of ghost
cities located across china
if you're not familiar with china's
ghost cities these are essentially
massive developments that never became
inhabited
times you see dozens of skyscrapers and
buildings that are completely empty and
sometimes not even finished
now you might be wondering how in the
world do these ghost cities even form in
the first place well if we take a look
at chinese real estate law we'll quickly
begin to understand how exactly this
happened china separates real estate
development into a few different
categories starting with economically
affordable housing china requires that
such projects are occupied by the owner
and these projects cannot be bought or
sold as an investment on top of this
real estate companies cannot sell these
properties for more than five percent
over the construction cost so these
projects aren't particularly lucrative
or appealing one category that is super
appealing though is commodity housing
which can be bought and sold as an
investment in most cases and in china
there's extraordinary demand for real
estate real estate is often thought of
as the best way to grow generational
wealth so even many middle class
families opt to buy second and third
properties as soon as they can afford it
also china has yet to experience a 2000
sale housing market collapse so as far
as the everyday chinese person knows
real estate prices only go up and
honestly this is not a bad bet
even if there is a crash it's just a
matter of time until real estate
recovers because people will always need
land but here's the problem you can't
own land in china so if you want a piece
of real estate in an area that you think
will develop in 20 or 30 years you have
to build something on it right now and
when millions of chinese people are
thinking the same thing it doesn't take
long to garner enough demand to build an
entire go city so while these cities are
indeed mostly if not completely empty
they're also completely sold out this
has provided chinese real estate
developers with unprecedented demand but
when all of your demand comes from
investors and not people who are looking
for a primary residence it just takes
one market downturn to obliterate your
demand
but wait a minute there's no way the
chinese government didn't see what was
happening right how did they not think
to stop this unsustainable practice
well the answer is twofold first of all
local governments are super incentivized
to sell land rights to these developing
companies you see municipal governments
only get to keep about 40 percent of
their country's tax revenue the rest
must be passed on to the ccp however
local governments have to pay for 80 of
their expenses so local governments have
to do something to overcome this funding
disparity and the easiest answer for
them has been selling land rights in
2015 for instance land transferring fees
accounted for 40 to 60 percent of local
government revenue this is not that
surprising when you consider that land
sales brought in 438 billion for local
governments in 2012. i don't think i
need to explain why local governments
were a fan of ghost cities but what
about the ccp
surely they could see that this was a
massive bubble waiting to blow up right
well they did and they would eventually
take action but not before letting the
situation get too far out of hand you
see it the ccp was also massively
incentivized to turn a blind die to
these ghost cities the ccp wasn't
directly pulling in cash from land sales
like local governments but they were
able to pump up the chinese gdp
the chinese real estate industry
accounts for 29 of the entire country's
gdp
so letting these ghost cities pop up was
extremely beneficial in terms of
catching up and beating the us in terms
of gdp at first this wasn't a big issue
as real state developers were pretty
responsible financially but it didn't
take long for greed to kick in for
developers like evergrand they started
taking out substantially more debt and
their debt equity ratio fell off a cliff
for example in 2014 evergrand had 112
billion won in equity and 206 billion
won in assets this gave them an
extremely healthy debt to equity ratio
of 0.839 meaning that they had more
equity than debt by 2020 their equity
had grown to 350 billion yuan which
sounds good until you realize that their
assets have grown to 2.3 trillion yuan
this results in a super dangerous debt
to equity ratio of 5.57
if evergrand was an average american
they would have had to take off pmi or
private mortgage insurance because they
didn't even have 20 equity this issue
wasn't just limited to evergrand either
many chinese real estate companies were
in similar positions which made it
abundantly clear to the ccp that they
had to take action
in august of 2020 chinese regulators met
with the country's largest real estate
companies including evergrand and they
introduced three restrictions called the
three red lines these restrictions put
caps on three debt ratios which were
debt to cash debt to equity and debt to
assets as you would guess afrogrand did
not exactly fall within these
restrictions so they would start selling
off properties and raising cash for
example in september of 2020 they
discounted properties by 30 percent to
increase sales similarly in october they
raised 555 million by completing a share
offering they also cancelled certain
projects but none of this was enough to
improve their financial situation
substantially nonetheless african was
able to stay afloat thanks to sufficient
cash flow but it didn't take long for
this to go downhill as well
in late 2020 jack ma and the ccp would
get into a bit of a conundrum which
prompted the ccp to crack down on
chinese tech companies while most of the
ccp's actions were directly targeted
towards tech companies as tech stocks
crumbled so did investor confidence and
as investors started pulling back on
real estate investment africa's net
profit started to decline as well in
august of 2021 africa reported 29
year-over-year decline in net profit and
given evergrand's already fragile
position this was enough for default
fears to go rampant african continued to
insist that while they were facing
issues there was nothing to worry about
you could say that these were their
famous last words as evergrand would
miss their first set of coupon payments
just a few weeks later shortly after a
program would begin missing coupon
payments on a regular basis until they
eventually defaulted on 1.2 billion
dollars worth of debt
the ccp has never publicly acknowledged
that they're billing out evergrand but
that's basically what they've been doing
they're not exactly saving the company
itself but they're trying their best to
ensure that the collapse of evergrand
does not lead to further consequences
and the main way they're accomplishing
this is by nationalizing the company for
example local governments have been
seizing rights granted to evergrand
similarly china's central bank freed up
188 billion dollars to help alleviate
any liquidity problems caused by
evergren's default evergrand has also
been selling parts of their own business
to raise cash and to pay off debt so at
this point it does look like china has
evergrand under control and that they'll
be able to contain a crisis but only
time will tell do you think the
evergreen crisis is behind us or is it
just a preview as to what's to come
comment that down below
also drop a like if you think that
china's ghost cities are spooky and of
course consider joining our discord
community to suggest future video ideas
and consider subscribing and see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm hari and i'll see you guys on
the next one
you